If you are married and have wanted to have a child for some time,...
...Pulau Dayang Island, which means "Pregnant Maiden Island," is worth a visit.
According to a legend, women get pregnant when they stay on Pregnant Maiden Island.
Do you want to know where it is?
This island is one of the 104 islands,...
...which constitute Langkawi on the west coast of Malaysia.
Langkawi is the most famous vacation spot in Malaysia.
The largest island is called Langkawi Island...
...where you can enjoy pristine white sandy beaches...
...and crystal clear turquoise water.
There are other quite large islands...
...such as Pulau Singa Besar (Big Lion Island) and Beras Basah Island,...
...but others are just little atolls about the size of a standard house.
The important thing to know is that if you like duty-free shopping,...
...you are in paradise here.
The whole island is a duty-free zone and there are no taxes.